Here the factored forms for each part of the fraction. Great work if you got all
of these correct. If you made a mistake that's okay too. Now's a great time to
go back and look over your work. See if you can figure out how to get these
factors. If not, you can always watch the solution. For our first numerator we
can remove a 2 x squared as the greatest common factor. This leaves us with x
squared plus 4 x plus 3 for our second factor. Now we can easily factor this one
by finding factors of 3. That sum to positive 4. That would be positive 3 and
positive 1. This is why it's important to find a greatest common factor first.
If we don't find this greatest common factor we won't be able to factor each
these and cancel our factors in the end. For this denominator we have a
coefficient of 1 in front of the x squared term. So we just want to find factors
of negative 15 that add to 2. This would be positive 5 and negative 3. For this
numerator the greatest common factor of the three terms is 1. So we just want to
find factors of negative 50 that sum to positive 5. The factors would be
negative 5 and positive 10 and then we can use factoring by grouping. To get our
factors of x plus 5 and 2 x minus 5. For our last denominator we can remove a
common factor of 6 x from every single term. If we factor the 6 x as a greatest
common factor, we're left with 2 x squared plus 3 x plus 1. If we distribute
this really quickly we can make sure that this is correct. When we look at
factoring this expression, we want to value in factors of positive 2 that sum to
positive 3. We can use factoring by grouping. To arrive at the factors of x plus
1 times 2 x plus 1. These factors take the place of this quadratic trinomial.
Now we're ready to simply our fractions since everything's in factored form.
Great work.